today we're going to go through some of
the best ideas of all time yeah well
purely subjective I have me and you so
yeah who knows the best ideas that we're
aware of right now that may change
but that's the beauty of it it's an
infinite game okay so the first one is
optimism a scam what's the Skeptics is
it shut down the railways shut down
Airlines shut down electricity shut down
it all it's all a scam we need more
nihilism we need more pessimism No I um
I wrote this essay called is optimism a
scam and the pure thesis behind it was
what you had about 20 years ago was the
secret the book that came out and it was
this idea that you could just manifest
things into reality and the cynical
skeptical crowd completely describes to
destroy the idea
and I always use like this so there's
three great examples of the secret so
you've got one which is Winston
Churchill when he was 19 years old
saying one day this great City will be
under attack I will be the one that
saves it so that's like 50 40 50 years
before World War II you have Arnold
Schwarzenegger saying I will become the
greatest bodybuilder ever and the
greatest movie star or the biggest movie
star at the time there's one which is
from John Rockefeller as well which is
one day I will be the richest man in the
world he said that to his bank teller
who had rejected him for a bank
apparently so that's the kind of ball
case for like ridiculous affirmations
that manifest reality but the problem
with that is for every Rockefeller
Schwarzenegger Churchill there's 10 000
delusional that say these
things and they are backed up so the
Skeptics are right there
um and the problem that the optimism
crowd has in my opinion it's a marketing
problem they've sold it they've oversold
it and the best the best put down ever
was Dave Chappelle where he's saying if
the secret was true
why aren't all the starving kids in
Africa manifesting food
and you go that's that's the ultimate
win right so optimism as a result has
kind of struggled a few out and the
problem with optimism is they've
oversold the product is my is my thesis
so imagine if you sold creatine as human
growth hormone that's what I see people
have done with optimism so what we need
to do is appeal to Skeptics language to
kind of win the optimism game which is
if you go to PubMed and search placebo
effect 100 000 results everybody in the
scientific Community acknowledges the
power of the placebo effect there's one
uh study where it started in World War
II I forgot the name of the doctor where
it was the US versus the Italians and
there was loads of people loads of uh
um soldiers sorry struggling and rather
than give the morphine because he'd run
out he started giving them salt water
and they could go through surgery a bit
so the placebo effect is something
magical it's something powerful and
therefore I think you can use that a
little bit to argue the Skeptics case
for optimism and ultimately where I go
down this is what optimism is is to
improve one percent every single day so
this have you heard of the cocktail
party effect have I told you about that
no so the cocktail party effect is me
and you sat here like we've been in a
few bars or restaurants at Terry's
barbecue down the road right and the
background noise is a blur it's me and
you chatting blah blah blah blah blah
but if somebody says
Voodoo events which is Chris's old
events company or mentions the northeast
of England or whatever it is suddenly
that background noise what is that
um you immediately tune into it so right
now your brain is blurring out infinite
inputs millions of inputs that are
happening right now and you're focusing
on what appeals to your reticular
activating system and I think the the
case for optimism is
you're not going to manifest things into
reality but if you have a more
optimistic frame you're more likely to
spot those opportunities and I say
Market optimism is a one percent
Improvement every single day and then
you'll probably get more people to
believe it so I think that's the problem
with optimism it was oversold yeah the
baby in bath water got thrown out
together exactly the fruit yeah I put
that baby in bath water meme which is
they throw the baby out
um which is like useful optimism with a
load of delusional wishy-thinking
Instagram quotes and that's
problem especially the first kind of
like Eugenics optimisms like Eugenics
that the first iteration of really
really aggressive optimism came from
Ronda burns the secret this is the woman
who said that the 2006
Boxing Day tsunami that killed like tens
of thousands of people I think in
Thailand was due to the Thai people
giving out bad vibes that like
manifested and attracted this natural
disaster it's like it's like if you
advertise creatine is going to fix
everything it's not it's a small one
percent Improvement every day but the
actual difference is is you may then
have an opportunity that opens up that
completely compounds so I think James
Clear has that graph where if you
improve 0.1 every single day if that
compounds that's a 30 second 36x
Improvement in a year
um that's the argument I think for
optimism it's a one percent Improvement
every single day and ultimately Society
is getting better I think it's important
to repeat that point Well everybody's
deluded right in one form or another
everybody has some type of delusion as
far as I can see and both of us come
from the north of the UK this is like
the Ground Zero for cynicism
pessimism skepticism not necessarily
coming from an intellectual place but
almost coming from a genetic place it
feels like there's a predisposition the
weather's gray the people are gray the
mood is gray so
everybody has a degree of delusion right
why not have a delusion that benefits
you like if you're going to not be
accurate necessarily if you know that
you're going to be inaccurate about the
future and you know that you can't know
everything which is true
I don't think that
erring on the side of things are going
to get worse especially given that every
quantifiable metric available says that
things are getting better yes is it
difficult that we're dealing with the
existential pain of Life Direction and
all that stuff yeah 100 I I get that and
it's a luxurious position to be in to
have an existential crisis because all
of the bottom layers of Maslow's
hierarchy of needs have been sorted so
it's a challenge that very few people
have had to deal with so there's not any
wisdom that's been archetably passed
down over Generations because so few
people got to the situation where they
were safe from shelter and food and
water and connection and blah blah
meaning and all that stuff
so yeah I understand it's a difficult
challenge but like
everything is getting better which means
that
optimism
what looks like optimism is actually
realism and what looks like realism is
actually like pessimism yeah I think
anybody who follows me for a while
um and the ones who haven't and have to
describe this one's your listen uh audio
is there's this Matrix which is optimism
and pessimism and then low agency and
high agency and I feel that but yeah if
you have optimism with a low sense of
agency that that isn't valuable at all
but paired with high agency I think
that's one of the most beautiful things
there's this like one thing that I
always come back to as well which is
this Steve Jobs email I think I told you
about this one where he sent to himself
13 13 months before he died it came out
quite recently and Steve Jobs wrote this
to uh to himself I grow little of the
food I eat and the little I do grow I
did not breed or perfect the seeds I do
not make any of my own clothing I speak
a language I did not invent or refine I
did not discover the mathematics I use I
am protected by freedoms and laws I did
not conceive or of or legislate and do
not enforce or adjudicate I am moved by
music I did not create myself when I
needed medical attention I was helpless
to help myself survive I did not invent
the transistor the microprocessor object
oriented programming or most of the
technology I work with I love and admire
my species living and dead and I am
totally dependent on them for my life
and well-being the one guy who could
have a could be very pessimistic in that
scenario but B also
rightly so have a ego
um it's so like that that I always come
back to that whenever I feel quite
pessimistic I go life's actually
very very good how do you reframe it
yourself so everybody has this draw
towards cynicism pessimism it's cool to
do it on the internet somehow becomes
sexy to be cynical because it's seen as
like a signal of high intellect how do
you stop yourself tumbling down that
rabbit hole
it's a good question I think one of them
I have this thing of like Hardware
versus software which is most people
think they have a software problem when
they actually have a hardware problem so
if I'm finding myself thinking more
cynically thinking more negatively I'll
just try and fix the hardware so it's
like some kind of breathing exercise
sauna run exercise eat well my friend
Dicky says that when he's tired uh or in
that kind of emotional state his goal of
the day is just to make no decisions so
I just often a good night's sleep or
whatever it is try and fix it that way
that for me fixes about 95 of my
software problems and then the remaining
five percent which may be legitimate
issues are much easier to solve in that
so that's the first thing I'd say is fix
Hardware before you try and fix software
um and then I think it's a lot about who
you're around it's a lot about studying
studying history is super important
because you go I could have been
born in 1612 yeah or I could have been
part of World War II which was a blink
of an eye away um and when you actually
look at it from a historical perspective
it's like well where's better than now I
don't think there is a better time than
now yeah I came up with this yesterday I
told you about the alpha history fantasy
oh yeah yeah so uh modern men who are
angry at the world they feel has
rejected them mistakenly believe they
would have done better in medieval times
they're somehow adamant that the chance
of them being Genghis Khan is greater
than the chance of them being Canon
fodder peasant number one million 373
582 whose Favela was sacked and
destroyed that would have been me yeah
you think he would have been Cannon for
the peasant 100 okay well I think um
heberman's got this quote where he says
you cannot change the mind to the mind
you have to change it with the body it's
not strictly true because meditation is
precisely changing the mind with the
mind but I think broadly it's true that
most of the problems that people
encounter are Hardware problems rather
than software problems I learned this
during covid for the first time in my
entire life I had a stable sleep and
wake pattern I went to bed and got up at
the same time seven days a week for the
first time since I was 18. I was 32. so
I'm like right okay
there's something to this there's
something to having a set routine and
I'd listen to I'd sent it to you I
remember sending to you uh Matthew
Walker on Rogan being like wow look how
important sleep is meanwhile staying up
until four in the morning cashing up
nightclubs like two or three nights a
week so you need to really sort of see
it and feel it yes on a hardware problem
also
I had this idea called the cynicism
safety blanket I don't know that one
I'm happy with this so this is
explaining why cynicism is uh incredibly
trendy especially in the modern world
cynicism is a guarded response which
sets yourself up against disappointment
its role within the system is to protect
you against experiencing anything bad it
is a preemptive strike against a
perceived threat if I tell myself that
all women are bad then I'm less likely
to seek relationship with women and as a
consequence I'm never going to feel the
pain of rejection if I tell myself that
everything is or that things will
never get better then I am excused of
ever having to try at anything it's more
comfortable to get fatalistic and call
it pragmatism the cope is framing hope
as pathetic and embarrassing and
optimism is delusion it's sour grapes at
an existential level if everything sucks
and everyone is horrible and the reality
is disappointing and you know that for a
fact then it's the people acting like
things that can be better that are dumb
delusional and the problem
the upside of never trying is never
having to feel the pain of failure and I
also think that ties into the cocktail
party effect what we just spoke about
where if you have that cynical Outlook
and you have that pessimistic Outlook I
mean you can still win the lottery of
course but you will if there's so much
sensory inputs that's trying to go into
your brain you will just see it more you
will see more of it you'll end up down
darker YouTube rabbit holes you'll end
up watching those things you'll end up
in those suspects so it's this kind of
Perpetual flywheel that then begins to
compound yeah you're looking both ways
yeah you're looking for evidence that
confirms the world view that you didn't
want to have but that you somehow have
inculcated from being on the internet
too much Scott Adams the credit deal but
he has this idea in one of his books
where it's called the weed filter and he
used to think that if he smoked weed
people became way nicer to him so he
started smoking more and more weed and
then he began to realize actually he was
just more relaxed because he was so
tight and stiff that all of a sudden his
interaction with the world also has an
effect on how they interact with him
when he was way more relaxed people were
then way more relaxed around him it
wasn't actually that we only realized it
wasn't actually the weed itself it was
purely the filter that he was viewing
things through
um yeah it's trying to push optimism is
a tough it's a it's tough yeah it's a
really hard road yeah I mean I then like
going back to what we said is you didn't
have Hardware software I think it's more
just looking around just looking at the
reality of the situation one of my
favorite stories is uh I forgot the
writer who did it but he tried to make a
chicken sandwich from scratch have you
heard this story he tried to create a
chicken sandwich purely from scratch so
the first principle sandwich first
principles took him six months it cost
him 1500 pounds oh so you had to grow
the wheat or whatever that was ground up
to make the flower to do that right okay
you just you just don't think about
those things of how
really when you look at human beings
there's nothing actually that special
about them but the ability a to create
ideas which we spoke about to begin with
and then B the ability to cooperate at
scale it's that thing about if you try
to create a pencil you couldn't no one
knows how to create a pencil because the
like rubbers from here the leads
from here no one knows it and that is
quite beautiful and you need optimistic
people in order to be able to
collaborate to play those positive some
games it's so important and listen is it
going to fix cancer if you've got cancer
of course not but like one of my
favorite examples is Brian Armstrong who
used to do write down every single day I
will create a billion dollar company
do I think that created a billion dollar
company no of course not it was like
hard work he's probably ridiculous IQ
he's probably got a great Network he had
the right idea he went through y combat
he had all those things but could that
have helped a little bit possibly
I would love to see the case for
pessimism like the only reason that I
can see that pessimism would potentially
be the case that would be put forward
would be that it protects people
emotionally from the pain of failure
that's really the only thing if you set
your sights so low you can never be
disappointed by reality I mean one of
the things I'd kind of thought this
conversation here is I do think there's
there's some utility to pessimism and
like that kind of George orwellian
double thing like the ability to hold
two ideas at the same time is so
important so if you can actually take a
pessimistic frame and go oh what's the
worst scenario that can happen here it's
that Tim Ferriss fear setting idea I
think that's super valuable as well
um and the ability to constantly use
optimism and pessimism when you need it
but I'd say on the whole I think
optimism's more useful I likewise if you
can take a high agency frame when you
need it and also the ability to
empathize with what the low agency
version of this will be the ability to
operate in multiple mindsets I think
super important is that George
Fitzgerald quote which is like you can
tell the
you can tell the mark of a first-rate
intellect by the ability to hold two
thoughts two opposing thoughts at the
same time and that's very rare these
days people either go to one end of the
spectrum or the other and I'm often
quite obsessed with what's that
third door yeah
orthogonally yeah because this team's
here this team's here what's that here
you've mentioned it a couple of times
today one of mine in your favorite words
High agency yeah why are you so obsessed
with high agency people why is it
important
because it's applied optimism I guess
without it nothing changes and we was at
dinner last night with Jared and we were
saying to I asked he for reference for
the audience he recruits that high level
execs and I asked him what do all these
guys have in common when you get to like
that Uber level of big big big companies
and he said like energy transference and
high Agency for me is a combination of
energy transference the ability to
either just accept the story or change
the story and then you have this kind of
debate again you can have these two
thoughts in your head at the same time
of the great man theory of history or
um kind of things just happen societally
and change that way and again I think
there's truth truth to both but
ultimately the at the individual level
having a sense of agencies extremely
valuable and these figures like one of
my favorite questions to ask is
what films aren't we making because
we're too busy making Transformers 12.
and if you actually look at all my work
it's often questions rather than answers
it's my favorite Oasis lyric is
questions are the answers you might need
and often in this platform it's a guru
platform you can give these easy
platitudes I actually prefer to ask a
question and then leave that open loop
with the audience and then go hey here's
my answer to the question but then you
may get and hopefully we do you get a
lot of DMS from people going actually
this is the story that they should be
making instead of Transformers 12. have
you heard about this person have you
heard about this person or have you
heard about this story
um or were you crowdsourcing the
insights exactly and that I think that's
such a better way it goes back to what
we said at the beginning that's an
infinite game where if you try and go I
think XY Dead's true and I have this
Guru Insight of ABC versus having a
question of an open loop those are
questions that you can kind of answer
over a career and still never answer
it's an infinite game okay so high
agency is the ability to change to enact
change if it was to be in a single
sentence I would say it's that yeah I
think uh low agency is life happening to
EU High agency is you happening to life
I'd say that's the fundamental
difference and you'll know people who
life happens to them and then you know
people who happen to life and ultimately
it's a constant battle you can have the
most high agency Steve Jobs who dies of
pancreatic cancer
um obviously the stuff around the
characters and things like that but but
ultimate environments still have a
factor but it's the ability to have that
double think and know okay well I can
still have the most amount of optimism
still the most about high agency and
have an impact environments are still
going to have a huge impact too so who
are some of your favorite High agency
humans throughout history going back to
what I said earlier of what films aren't
Hollywood making right now because
they're making Transformers 12 of Fast
and Furious 15.
um the most underrated one in terms of
how few people know and the most high
agency individual is a guy called
rudolferber so Rudolph Verma
um was in auswitch as a teenager
um he was in a unique position where he
was essentially in the operations of the
train so he would help Jews come off the
trains
um particularly women and children and
then they get exported to the gas
Chambers one of the things like I met a
principal today today that I've kind of
massively changed my mind the last 24
months is when you when you study
history you begin to understand things
completely differently so when I go into
this rudolfer story the thing that
people don't appreciate is they view it
in hindsight versus at the time the
Nazis didn't announce to people hey get
on these trains and this is what's going
to happen to you that wasn't the case
and as a result lots of other
governments who were fighting the war
against them didn't even know that was
the case there was a few people who
suspected it was but it's only in
hindsight do we know that so he then
began to see he was one of the few
people that knew who wasn't on the Nazis
team that could see this just killing
machine that was happening
um and okay so you can imagine here talk
about pessimism has every reason to be
pessimistic he's seeing the worst of
humanity that's ever existed talk about
agency he's literally a prisoner and if
you try and Escape out switch they will
they will just essentially if they find
you they'll put a three-day dog Squad
they will hunt you down and they will
hang you in front of the everybody else
just to show what happens to you so he
teamed up with Alfred wetzler
um actually just a rewind for a second
but the most harrowing thing about his
story going why why he could be so
pessimistic and solo agency is he meets
a girl in the concentration camp called
Alice Monk and loses his virginity in
the concentration camp and then she gets
killed the next day in the gas Chambers
and he kept seeing that and again talk
about pessimism talk about low agency
every single reason to be but decided
you know what it I'm gonna try and
Escape so he teamed up with Alfred
wetzler and essentially what they did
was there was some wood just outside the
camps that they hid under these barrels
of wood Boom the Nazis as they're
counting in at the and they go where's
44070 because they take their names from
them so they just have numbers
where are they they released the dog
Squad and they hid under these barrels
of Ward the most high agency part of it
they cover themselves in gasoline and
tobacco so the Nazi dogs couldn't find
them even though they were right
literally on the perimeter there's one
point where they almost find them and he
has a knife because he's about to take
his own life
okay they don't find them three days
goes by they haven't air they've kind of
stayed awake they escape
um they Sprint as fast as they can run
all the way through Slovakia
no good run through Slovakia in
concentration camp uniforms where
everyone surrounding them a Nazi
sympathizers because that's what they
put in place with no Google Maps no Uber
no fight no no no WhatsApp to chat to
this like the squad you know I mean like
this is like the most harrowing thing
where and if they get caught killed
immediately
um run I think it's like a hundred and a
hundred or so Miles through get all the
way there and then the most beautiful
part is kind of the few things that
happens afterwards so one rather than
write an incredibly emotional Rapport
which you should have done like they
killed the girl he lost his virginity to
right it's dark you could tell them like
they killed the girl I looked they wrote
the most objective mckinsey-like Rapport
of this killing machine that was
Auschwitz
um
and that people didn't believe them for
quite a while again rather than rest on
his Laurels this guy goes and joins the
Slovakian Army and they say we're not
going to give you a pistol we'll give
you a machine gun because of like the
kind of guy you are just based off this
story yeah we don't give boys
like you pistols yes we give we give
them uh machine guns so that's the kind
of guy again just Escape that but he's
back on the front line
the beautiful thing well there's a dark
side and there's a beautiful side but
the dark side is because going back to
what I said earlier people didn't
understand what was happening at the
time it wasn't believed for a while
until Churchill and the pope ultimately
got the report and then began to put
more and more pressure on the Nazis
um so it was a big factor they recommend
the reckon uh they reckon he saved 200
000 lives just from his actions alone
after the war he goes and lives in
America he's a lecturer at pharmacist
pharmacology basically none of his
students know the story of what he did
and the most beautiful thing I found a
YouTube video that has 56 views on it
where this guy who used to know him very
well said that everybody apart from
verba who he knew that escaped or went
through Auschwitz
um verba dressed insanely well because
he never wanted that freedom to be taken
away from him ever again so he dressing
like the most outlandish amazing suits
and for me talk about a film that is
better than Transformers 12. better than
Fast and Furious 8 but nobody knows who
I mean a few people do but most people
do not know who he is and why isn't
there a day named after him it's it's
for me it's Insanity the most high
agency man of all time I think in terms
of uh name to agency ratio yeah name to
awareness it's Rudolph for sure that's
very cool yeah the um I put dick Fosbury
in the tedx talk that I did a few years
ago and I think that that's a good
example as well uh you know someone who
was being maligned in a very different
way but he was mocked you know to to try
and break the existing hegemony that was
the scissor kick I think was the current
one that people were using uh and he was
an engineer by trade so he had analyzed
what was happening with regards to
center of gravity how he could get
yourself as low as possible and yeah he
was laughed at by everybody you know he
he competed in the Olympics I think it
was maybe uh Japan or Korea or somewhere
like that in the 60s when he did win he
had two different pairs of Nikes on he
didn't have the same pair of shoes and
he missed the opening ceremony because
he wanted to go to a museum so this guy
was an unbelievable outlier but he had
the courage of his convictions and I
think that that's that's one of the big
differences oh it's that idea which is
if he was to go back to 1850 and try and
explain the concept of Wi-Fi it would
blow their but it would not be seen as
fathomable but the idea exists you just
needed a combination of ideas what we
spoke about earlier and then High agency
individuals and Humanity uh working
together and compounding so the question
you then think is but what is going to
be Wi-Fi for us now they're 100 years
from now however long it's gonna be oh
that was so obvious like one of my
favorite examples which is a much more
base level is wheeled suitcases so
before I think it was
1970s everybody used to carry their
suitcases everywhere Eric Weinstein has
that great bit of
the smartest men at the time the
smartest physicist used to get on the
train or the plane carrying their their
suitcases and the question is is well
where's the Wheeled suitcases right now
there's one guy who comes along and goes
hold on let's put some wheels on that
Jim Jefferies has a great bit in his new
Netflix special where he says feasibly
Neil Armstrong as he was getting on the
Rockets I was there carrying on his
suitcases because one day we'll put a
rocket on these without realizing okay
so and that's again going back to
questions questions are the answers that
you need where is the Wheeled suitcase
right now and that's a question that can
keep you up at night where it's so
obvious but everyone's just copying the
crowd and being nomatic so a lot of
people will think I would be high agency
I want to be around people that are high
agency how can you tell if your friends
and the people that you hang with are
high or low agency
I I think going back to what we
mentioned earlier which is do they kind
of bend the environment so no matter
what situation you put them in do they
bend it
um the the dinner last night he said
energy transference so I had this essay
I've never pulled the published which is
sofa friends versus treadmill friends
and there's certain friends that I hang
around with afterwards I need to lie on
a sofa because they kind of drain you of
that energy and then there's other
friends that we mean you know where you
hang around with them and you're like
seven mile run let's go we
overclock our brains that's so I think a
big thing that you'll see is energy
transference I I always say that uh
Steve from Diary of a CEO who I used to
work at his company there was this thing
where I would walk in the office in the
morning and I'd open the door and bear
in mind Steve could be in the London
office Manchester office Berlin office
New York office he's constantly jet
setting around and I go I could just see
from people's faces and how much energy
was in the room I got our Steve's here
today without even seeing him and I
think that's like often thing is when
they enter a room the energy just
completely changes I think that's often
combination of high agency individuals
you had weird teenage Hobbies we are
teenage Hobbies is another one so
I often hire for this like I can be a
job interview and if they mention a
weird teenage hobby I kind of lean in
quite a lot which I probably shouldn't
say probably you know because now people
are going to start bringing those up but
when you're young then it when
especially when you're a teenager it's
probably your low most low Agency State
because you want to copy the crowd you
want to be mimetic of everybody around
you however if you can at that age
whilst everyone else is going playing
football or rugby be super into yo-yoing
or super into football freestyle or
super into whatever it is for me that's
a good sign because if you can swim
against the tide When You're 15 or the
environment of people mocking you so
much easier as you're an adult well it's
so formative as well right A lot of the
things that you do in later life or
Echoes of what you did when you were a
kid yeah there's a really great study
that I looked at that the music that you
listen to between the ages of 11 and 15
imprints on you for the rest of your
life wow so that's why you have
generations of Music trends that go like
I still love emo and post hardcore
because I grew up in like the Hawthorne
Heights and blink 18 to era that was my
that was what I listened to right and
then there'll be other people that
listen to whatever it might be you know
God help the people that are growing up
now like Megan D Stallion and cardi B
but um you've got the golden question as
well which is something that we've used
I think you might have spoken about this
on the first ever episode that we did
what's what's the golden question the
golden question is if he was stuck in a
third world prison or you were stuck on
an island and you had to call someone to
bail you out who would you call and that
alone will identify the most high agency
person in your life because within that
you need a combination of I mean some
kind of delusional optimism to be able
to pull that off you need some
Relentless kind of resourcefulness to
try and operationalize that and you're
going to need to be
have that energy transference to be able
to convince people or whatever the
whatever plan you're gonna have to put
together so I'd say that is probably the
most impactful thing when predicting
High agency one that I see as well is
immigrant mentality so
if somebody's moved from their hometown
quite a good sign if someone's moved
from their home country even greater
sign and you then see these like
immigrants across particularly America
right who absolutely dominate because if
you can sit there and go I'm in the
wrong place
and so I have to acknowledge Him in the
wrong place I have to admit I think
everybody else or other people around me
I disagree with their decision at least
for me
um and to have the growth mindset to
then operationalize a move and start
from zero that event itself is kind of
quite a meta story it doesn't mean that
every everybody who uh migrates is high
agency but I'd say it is quite common
not being able to predict people's
opinions as well I think is I have a
friend of mine called catty and I love
hanging around with him because I don't
know what he's going to say because I
like he he doesn't just line up with oh
uh for example like you'll have like the
bodybuilder who you'll stereotype them
you probably get this a little bit as
well right people don't expect you to be
in great shape form a model and then
chat about Neuroscience with a guy
coming on and hold your own so I love
people when you can't fully predict
their opinions or you have
um The Beauty Queen who's super into
Nietzsche or the marketer who's obsessed
with the history of War whenever someone
just falls into that obvious stereotype
makes you think that they haven't
thought about things but when they go
hold on a second like you was on love
Island but you're super into talking
about astrophysics dagger that's
probably quite a high agency individual
because they've they've clearly gone
against what should be their default
programming yeah if you know one opinion
that somebody holds and from it you can
accurately predict everything else that
they believe yeah they're probably not a
serious thinker they're just they're
just NPCs just downloading scripts but
there is somebody out there who falls
into the perfect mold of uh I am
pro-life and I'm pro-gun and I'm Pro
First Amendment and I'm like small
government and I'm like anti-immigration
and I'm blah blah blah like you are the
complete caricature stereotype of the
person that's from the right and there
is the same from the person that's from
the left but most people are so
idiosyncratic that you should have
something that doesn't fit should be
this nice smooth Circle except for those
two bits you're like what's that doing
there like why are you uh pro-choice but
pro-gun or why are you like uh
pro-immigration but pro-small government
like why did those things go together
and when you find somebody that has
a non-typical suite of beliefs
it's interesting because you think oh
you've arrived at this point on your own
this is one of the things I did this
video about Sam Harris ages ago
three four years ago why Sam Harris is
annoying everybody it seems like he he's
like continued like true to form over
the last few years
um but I have to respect what he's done
with regards to that because he pays an
unbelievably high price to hold the
opinions that he does which gives me a
great amount of faith that he truly
believes in them it would be much easier
for him to fold either one way or the
other like how can it's a very untypical
to be pro-vax but anti-woke
like anti-trump but also kind of
anti-biden like you know he just holds a
suite of beliefs that whether you agree
with them or not and almost everybody
disagrees with some of them right
there's very few people that hold the
exact same as Sam Harris Suite of
beliefs that Sam Harris does but the
price that he pays to hold them is so
high
that for me it's a reliable signal of
authenticity because there are much
easier routes to existing in the world
than holding that odd conglomeration of
views um it makes you think they've
thought it through and I realized the
favorite my favorite people to hang
around and I don't have to agree with
them on anything but have they thought
things through I find that fascinating
and then do they update their beliefs
the other one on the high agency list
was
are they mean to your face
but nice behind your back and you often
don't see the people who are nice to
your face and mean behind your back
because by definition it's behind your
back so another concept we come on to is
hidden metrics but on that specific
thing it is a hidden metric you don't
see people being rude behind your back
and I think often a good indication of
somebody probably being nice behind your
back is probably someone who's mean to
your face well at least you know that
and if not at least they're consistent
what people that are nice about other
people who aren't there to your face
that's a good one or the inverse are
they amazing friend amazing friend
leaves the room and they go oh have you
seen what they're wearing or have you
seen XYZ that's for me a sign of like it
takes a lot of agency to go against
gossiping which is one of the most
innate human things correct being a
gossip tells you as much about the
person who is gossiping as it does about
the person that they're gossiping about
because what it tells you is that as
soon as the scrutiny of the person that
they're talking about is no longer there
they're going to be prepared to talk
about you I've said before like the
stuff that is on this
phone would break the internet for weeks
for weeks dude I have on there
which is
like crossover
dread pirate robbers
um
but I you know I it's my way of going
about life that I'm like okay well I
guess I'm just gonna like hold this
secret for the rest of time it's
exciting for me to have like one of the
other ones as well I think is um sending
people Niche content um going back to
the rudolfer story I found that from one
of the things talents I have that I
can't remonetize it I spot content
creators really early on going back to
begin the conversation probably listen
to you on the first ever episode it took
a while for that stock that penny stock
to finally boom it's doing well now
right
um and there's a lot of other examples
like that and one of the low agency
things is okay this has six million
views therefore I will click on it what
I now do is I'll go on the Twitter feed
or the YouTube explore feed or whatever
and I look for things the algorithm is
recommending me with like a very few
views and I click on that and list nine
out of ten times it's absolutely a waste
of time but one out of ten you'll tap
into something that everybody else isn't
tapping into but by definition that is
the meme of seeing a crowd like uh the I
create that Meme about how to be
productive versus how to be creative and
everybody's queuing outside how to be
productive but no one's queuing out how
to be creative but a meta level that's a
concept right of what are the things
that nobody's clicking on that will then
potentially be big in the future and you
have to do that like a VC where you know
nine out of 10 of your bets are going to
be completely incorrect but one out of
10 is clicking on a Bitcoin article in
2014. yeah like how many of you've had
what 30 million views on that verbal
story I think on Twitter because whereas
everyone else is then just regurgitating
the same versus if you can tap into
other inputs that was my big thing about
creativity the essay that went viral on
that which is creative the problem with
creativity is people treat it like
productivity where they just try and do
the same thing harder versus try and get
as many different inputs into the system
as possible and now YouTube explore page
and all these things can just keep you
in this hamster wheel so you need to try
and break out because you're predictable
and search weird things and before you
know it you find some bizarre inputs
that can either go one way or the other
yeah the niche content thing and looking
for different ideas and where do they
come from is a really interesting way to
conceptualize productivity versus
creativity really interesting idea to
look at there is what's the work
environment that you're doing this
particular job in so for instance if
you've ever walked into an artist studio
Zach my housemate his missus is an
artist right so I go into the room where
she does her art and there's stuff
everywhere there's like Vapes
and there's there's halfton sketches and
there'll be like a dog brush and they'll
be like a a Bluetooth speaker but it's
like upside down and there'll be can't
also it's chaos chaos that is
the place that you want to be and
there'll be books and all sorts of other
stuff that's the place that you want to
be if you want creative ideas it's not
the place you want to be in if you're
doing your taxes no when you're doing
your taxes you want to be a nice clean
desk you want to have all of your stuff
in front of you you don't have any
distractions and yeah the
Obsession that people have over
productivity is so all-encompassing that
I don't think many people in the modern
world have ever looked at a problem and
thought anything except for I need more
productivity every single lock gets
filled with the key of more focus more
productivity the reason I can't do this
is because I'm insufficiently attentive
well sometimes and maybe even a lot of
the time and this may be a comment on
how
um replicable and almost formulaic a lot
of people's jobs are now that you know
many roles should be concerned about the
forthcoming GPT Revolution but
a lot of the time okay what's the
creative angle to the thing that I'm
trying to do if you're trying to write a
book sometimes you need to sit down and
just put your nose against the
grindstone because you're not getting
the stuff out but if you're struggling
with ideas you probably need to go for a
walk yes
but we we come from an institutionalized
system which is the education system
which was designed to create factory
work I wondered when we would get onto
education it can't take you anywhere
without you blasting the education
system so I think that's that's
definitely a factor but it goes back to
that question of where is the
wheel suitcases and constantly asking
that at a societal level but even right
now in your very life like where is that
Simple Solution that's so obvious that's
just staring you in the face but because
you're trying to be so productive you
can't quite see it yeah so a good
example for me I've started doing
Barry's boot camp first thing in the
morning I've been telling you about this
I've been struggling with motivation to
train consistently I can train on a
weekend with friends but training on my
own is getting way way harder and I
think it's because I'm under a fair bit
of pressure with the show and I've known
for a very long time that classes for me
externalize my motivation they give me a
time that I need to be there they
condense down the training into a short
period of time there's a coach that
makes sure the programming and stuff it
outsources everything that I need to do
and I just forgot that that was an
option and then one day was walking past
Barry's on the way to go to flower child
where we went for dinner last night
thought I should I should book in to go
there sure enough signed up online and
I've been to tons and tons of classes
now and by 8 30 am
I've got 50 minutes of training in I've
done my morning routine and by 9am I can
be on a call having trained and done all
of my morning stuff I'm like wow even if
I'd been at home it would have I would
have struggled to have been as efficient
so oddly the creative solution has
opened up a degree of productivity as
well the three biggest things I found
for coming up with creative ideas
are one uh you can get this spinning
wheel app on your iPhone I just searched
Spinning Wheel app on uh the App Store
and collect going back to questions
early just collect great questions that
you hear like where's the Wheeled
suitcase right now in my life
and as you collect more of those
questions things you hear on podcast
things people say to you just spin that
wheel before bed
leave it with your subconscious
overnight and then journal on that thing
first thing before any any inputs
absolutely fantastic for coming up ideas
uh second biggest one is this idea
called sakoko I believe it how I know
that's how you actually pronounce it but
I was sat in the Maldives for a week
without any inputs and I came up with
this idea which is the if you ask
anybody where they want to travel
everybody certainly I know are like 90
say Japan why is Japan's why do people
want to travel to Japan so much but if
you study the history of Japan they
practice sokoko I believe again probably
butchering the pronunciation where they
closed the borders for 250 260 years
anybody who tried to leave and come back
killed anybody who tried to enter killed
and as a result whilst the rest of the
world was trading ideas it developed
this crazy insane beautiful unique
culture that where there's nowhere else
in the rest of the world and that's why
people want to go and visit it because
it's so creative and so new because it
wasn't Cosmopolitan it didn't get
diluted down by other cultures exactly
and then go back to the double think
idea though at the other end of a
spectrum is another tool which is that
if you search on YouTube Swedish House
Mafia creating one and it starts with
them like tapping like this and they go
all the way up to them just jamming in a
studio like three creative guys to
creating one live in like the space of a
minute of the edit and it's amazing and
you can see like you put three people in
a room with no inputs from the outside
world and they just pick a ball or idea
tennis their way to it so I think
Spinning Wheel helps
time alone definitely helps and the
longer the better
as well as getting some kind of idea
camp with the smartest people you know
and just and shutting out the world that
way we came up with similar ideas I came
up with anxiety cast and you came up
with thinking costs what's thinking cost
thinking cost everyone will relate to
which is this idea that your brain is a
supercomputer
but and you can try this I'll give this
as an experiment to anyone listening
right now try and have two thoughts at
the same time and maybe there's the
elite IQ guys that me and you definitely
aren't and the Nicola Tesla's out there
that could do it but I can't have two
thoughts at the same time so with that
in mind you've got this weird thing
where you have a supercomputer but it
can only one run one program at a time
quite a quite a particle the human brain
Paradox and why this is interesting is
when you have super dramatic super
negative people
going back to what we said at the
beginning where ideas are probably the
most important thing it's hard to think
about the wheels on suitcases when
your girlfriend's rhyme with you about
XYZ or somebody in the WhatsApp chat
kicking off and you and then because
what people don't see which is a hidden
metric but everybody has it well I know
I have it so I think everybody else has
it which is when those events happen
then when you're in the shower it's
running and it's just eating away that
super cute super computers Ram
constantly so there's a opportunity cost
that exists for every single thought so
whenever you have a thought there's
trillions other thoughts that you could
be having but because your supercomputer
can only run one program at a time it's
not having so you've got to have a
defense and an offense system that I
think anyway so the defense system is
avoid dramatic people as much as you can
Paul Graham has my favorite essay ever
which is life is short and I read it
whenever either anybody gets sick or
anybody dies and he kind of closes the
whole thing off of like relentlessly
prune so just get relentlessly
prune whenever it gets in your
life prune it purely because there's a
thinking cost to everything that you do
or every thought that you have and all
so whenever but I never see what will
happen is you will still have those
dramatic Loops that get in there you
can't have a complete
um defense against them but then anchor
the thought which is whenever you have a
thought Loop that happens
what is the opportunity cost of this
thought like what is the wheels on
suitcase that I could be thinking about
instead and then you kind of Judo throw
its momentum against it so thinking cost
is the idea that every cost every
thought has an opportunity cost and you
should be hyper Vigilant to that yeah
Peterson said the first time I ever
brought him on the show about the price
that you pay for inaction contemplate
the price you pay for an action you're
already in a little hell you know
perfectly well it's going to get worse
the thing about inaction is that you're
blind to it do not make the assumption
that an action has no price and this is
the same thing that
the
thinking cost actually is the price that
you pay but it's so unseen right people
are prepared to waste the Peace of their
own mind over and over and over and over
again in order to not make a difficult
decision because the difficult decision
feels more real but peace of mind is one
of the
key desires that almost everybody should
be striving toward the problem with
peace of mind is it's a hidden metric so
if you kind of Zoom all the way out I
have a few fundamental questions I keep
going back to with all my writing and
then you kind of Zoom a bit higher and
it's the optimism High agency thing and
if you actually Zoom the highest point
which I've not actually written about
just yet which is kind of viewing
everything going back to Rick and
Morty's Roy or the video game of life
like it's a simulation hypotheses but
just forked that's more optimistic more
High agency which is the video game
hypothesis and one of my fundamental
things of this kind of religion
philosophy is metrics are one of the
most important things and one of the
reasons why people obsess over money is
because money and your bank account is
the best video game ever designed it's
multi multiplayer competing against
other people oh this person makes this
much I only make that much number going
up and as a result things like peace of
mind which is a metric that we can't
quite measure yet but we all feel it we
only really begin to look look at it
when we're in rehab or when we have an
anxiety attack on the bus into work or
whatever it is and that's why I think
hidden metrics once you see it well you
never see it but then once you kind of
mentally see it you begin to see it
everywhere hormuzy has that great bit of
the Instagram model you take the
Instagram model the Metro the visible
metric is quite clear right you get to
post her on your Instagram it's gray
everyone thinks you're cool but when you
kind of lie in bed at night with
somebody who got I have nothing in
common with you at all the damn problem
I'm sure he's happy but uh you don't see
the hidden metric
um
yeah why uh why is it that you are such
a fan of the Roy scene from Rick and
Morty it's the header on your Twitter
and you've got a hoodie you've got a
custom printed hoodie that I met you on
the way to Dubai because the mask as
well during covered with Roy on as well
I I think it's because it's the knit
like so one of my favorite things that I
began to notice that was happening is
you hit 25 and life goes mental so up
from 0 to 25 everybody's on the same
path pretty much this is the slight
variance but everyone has these guard
rails of first year second year third
year
um High School University but then you
hit 25 and there's so much variance that
happens where I have friends that are
selling nfts for ridiculous amounts of
money I've got friends going to prison
I've got friends having a baby like
there's so much variance that begin to
happen and you begin to go like
religion is quite a useful tool but as a
lot of people who are atheist agnostic
there's nothing out there that quite
exists and the simulation hypothesis is
probably the best we've got and it has
nihilistic isn't it like this
idea there's just infinite versions of
me sat in a machine but if I can move
that to like the video game hypotheses
where I know I began to notice that the
laziest people I know the most
nihilistic pessimistic low agency people
I know could sit and play a video game
for 15 hours and be amazing at it so I
have this theory that video game
designers know more about human
psychology than 99 of psychologists the
video game industry is bigger than music
TV and entertainment combined the amount
they know about human psychology I think
is fascinating so the kind of Roy is
just viewing Life as a video game and
trying to shift from first person
shooter of me identifying with this to
just third person whether it's true or
not probably not it might not be a video
game but is it a useful bleeder hat
probably yeah I think depersonalizing a
lot of things is good like that's one of
Peterson's questions right
um like treat yourself like you are
somebody you're responsible for helping
like treat your life like a character
that you are responsible for playing
it's the same as Rogan's thing uh
imagine that you're the hero of your own
story you know all of these like what
what do all of these different ideas
have in common it takes a third person
perspective it depersonalizes a lot of
the things that are going on to you
because it's very difficult to give
yourself
you're so
embedded
in the experience of being you and
there's so much going on
That clouds your ability to make good
decisions
that actually being able to have a third
person perspective is probably about as
close to a superpower as you can be and
gamification like people talk about God
is dead therefore what's the point why
do we do anything but with a video game
you're not replaying it for any reason
but it's just a game and I feel
there's so much to be unpacked about
video game psychology that can get
implied but the biggest thing or
certainly one of the biggest things is
this concept of metrics when you have a
clear metric that people can optimize
what's that the Cobra effect wherein uh
the Brit started offering Indians money
for uh
cobras because there was such a big
problem with them and then they started
breeding them so you know what a better
version of that is it was to do with
um rats another country they had a
massive problem with rats and what they
said was that they would pay people to
bring in rat tails what they realized
was that there was thousands and
thousands of tailless rats running all
over the city so that so that's it's you
uh keeper boy has that concept of
parametrics where you have two metrics
so if you have a customer support team
and you say hey increase decrease the
fraud rate well then they start treating
every single customer like a potential
fraud says yeah you may achieve that
goal but every customer hates you
forever good Hearts yes you need to
balance that with an opposing metric so
going back to like the money video game
which is a great video game but if you
could then have peace of mind as an
opposing metric and I wonder if you
could literally visualize Peace of Mind
as a dashboard that you could see every
single day I think the impact that would
have on people's lives would be so
significant 100 I mean you know this is
what people fundamentally don't
understand about homozy is that he finds
Peace of Mind through doing business so
and I didn't understand it until I
really really drilled drilled deep with
him and he may be lying to me and I
don't know but like at least what he
says is that he finds his most peace
when he's chasing money
so for him money and peace are the same
thing but because most people don't have
that particular opinion when it comes to
their work they can't they don't have
theory of mind to understand what it
would be like to be Alex homozy like
what would it be like for your work and
the most peaceful thing that you do to
align to the point where you and your
partner believe that not having kids is
a smarter idea because you can literally
serve the world better through Legacy
through a company than you can through
children well I challenge you that
people don't can't empathize with that
they maybe just have an added frame to
them correctly where people can always
think of a game they played that's so
addictive that they end up playing for
the sake of playing what were some of
what were some of yours did you ever get
addicted you've got your brothers like
professional Esports player he was very
very good so I saw that firsthand but
for me football freestyle was my thing
right so I'd train four hours every
single night and do that and then
decided I actually want to lose my
virginity at one point I stopped doing
that
um so when you have something that
you're just doing purely for the sake of
doing I mean you're doing this with a
podcast right yeah we spoke last night
and I said
you're the only person I know that would
have stuck at it as long as you did
without the metric really but you was
playing it purely for the sake of
playing it but your metric so the
difference your metric wasn't the
subscribers or the view count really
part of it for sure but I knew if it was
you would have quit yeah but it was
purely an infinite game that you was
playing and because it was such a
well-designed video game for you then it
keeps going the biggest uh the biggest
piece of advice for people that ask
about you know I want to start a podcast
like what should I do or how should I
begin or you know but what's your piece
of advice like if you don't enjoy it
don't do it because you are not it's
going to take you 150 episodes to earn
anything it's going to take you
400 episodes before you're probably
unless you're gotten existing platforms
can take you 400 episodes before anybody
really cares about what you're doing
it's going to take so long and that's
weekly an idea I have with that is
pricing things in so I I think it's a
hedge fund term where you kind of price
in upcoming events and when you're
starting new things like that so when I
take uefoiling which people who don't
know it's like a electronic surfing
everyone saw Mark Zuckerberg which is
one of my funnest videos you don't even
DJ Khaled DJ Khaled drop that clip in
there Dean um so with that one big thing
I've now recognized because I always
take new people with me I'll say to them
I go you're going to fall off 50 times
before you get good at this versus if
they don't if they come at it with just
oh I'm gonna I'm gonna be good at this
immediately and then they start falling
off it it immediately rocks their
self-esteem whereas if you say hey
they're gonna be 50 times before you get
good at it Mr B says that as well with
YouTube he goes just make 100 videos and
then and then we'll chat yeah and I
think you've got to constantly price and
things and go okay it's gonna take me 12
months in the gym before I see anything
and if you price that and I always like
really conservative pricing in because
that's how you say 500 episodes you've
got a new podcast and you get it at
episode 212 you feel great but if they
go into the mindset of well level one
it's going to work therefore but again I
I structure all my Apple notes to-do
list so like for the every single day
it's the most Lindy thing I've done for
years is level one thought dump dump
everything I've got to do today level
two decide on the levels and boom I'm
already feeling good and every project I
do will be designed like that because
just me writing down what I've got to do
I've already hit Level and I can feel
that momentum growing versus if it's
like have a successful day I'm
constantly trying to play level 32 and
failing so again it goes back to that
how do you given that what you've
suggested there is essentially to price
in difficulty and to also kind of have
low expectations of success how does
that marry with the Skeptics Guide to
optimism well it goes back to that one
percent every day it goes back to the
secret is like you're not going
to immediately change things you're
going to need to combine optimism
combine agency but the most important
thing is infinite games that you can
play for the sake of playing them that
that's exactly the thing called Mosey at
least the impression I have of him he's
he's doing it like a game and he wants
to do this until he dies and that's why
he can keep playing and keep companion
exactly the same with you with this
podcast which is why you didn't quit
it's going to be very difficult to be
beaten by somebody that isn't having fun
if you are yeah right like what's that
uh
Thiago Forte it's incredibly difficult
to compete with someone who's having fun
yeah so I that was thinking cast which
was yours anxiety cast was similar
um but a little bit more uh acute a bit
more short-term this is what I'd come up
with so as you identified uh you can
only have one thought at a time and by
making any kind of decision
um inevitably you're going to um
cut off some of the potential wasted
thoughts thinking about that undone task
so let's say every single morning when
you wake up your daily to-do resets
right I need to walk the dog and
meditate and and take a and and
speak to my mum or whatever it is that
you do every single day right there are
certain things that you do every single
day
the longer that you wait to do those
things the more time is taken up
thinking about the fact that you haven't
yet done those things which is an
argument for front loading stuff into
your morning right versus the interest
rate constantly yeah every single time
that you think I need to meditate today
I need to meditate today I need to
meditate today could have been that's
wasted thinking cost or anxiety cost as
I called it that you could have fixed by
simply meditating when you woke up and
looking at your day not only through
Ebbs and flows of energy but also in
terms of what captures a lot of my
thought what causes me stress
how can I get that so that it's and not
only here's the other thing not only do
you get to gain not thinking about the
thing and being anxiously concerned that
you still need to do it you also get to
sort of bask in this beautiful
self-righteous glow from your high horse
of productivity because you went out and
you fist it first thing in the
morning
it's perfect so um next stuff raises
both massive fans of razors
you did a super thread and one of the
I've selected some of my favorites I've
added in some of mine as well the first
one bragging razor if someone brags
about their successor happiness assume
it's half what they claim if someone
downplays their success or happiness
assume it's double what they claim the
map is not the terrain
a hundred percent
and there's obviously exceptions to the
rule but I think that's quite a
consistent rule that I see when I hear
someone particularly if it's money or if
it's things like that when they're
bragging overtly I'm ah probably don't
really believe this but if someone's
kind of playing it down there's a few
subtle towels it's the classic midwit
meme right you've got the probably my
favorite meme of all time which is the
low IQ guy on the left the kind of
Midway in the middle and the super high
IQ guy there where the low IQ guy says
I'm the guy on the left the guy in the
middle says I'm the guy on the right and
the guy on the right says I'm the guy on
the left so and you see this with wealth
as well you see the super rich try and
hide the welfare as it's the kind of
people who were like the money Twitter
crowd screenshot the Shopify store and
things like that where it's but why are
you trying to signal that when you're
trying to overtly signal you're probably
trying to compensate for something again
there's exceptions to the rule but when
someone's signaling so hard it's
probably a sign that they don't have we
were in fact we were in uh a location in
Austin over the weekend and a Gentleman
came up to us and one of the first
sentences out of his mouth was 1500
people in the world have started a one
billion dollar business I'm one of them
no I I believe you even less now anyone
who's seen Carl pilkington's if
you wanted to go
yeah yeah I um I think what it
kind of suggests when somebody does
steaming and
um
start with achievements first is or any
kind of bragging basically suggests to
us it's a low status very
easy to fake signal of authenticity
right like a hard uh signal of
authenticity would just be show me a
bank balance or Show Me Your Capacity is
someone telling you how smart they are
is way less reliable of a signal than
someone having a conversation with you
that flows perfectly and you think holy
like that's really cool so yeah I
you know we're into personality quirks
here around people's desire to be seen
and their needs for validation from the
world around them but I think generally
the bragging razor of thinking
if
I want to come across well allowing my
achievements to arise as a byproduct of
someone asking me about what I do this
is another thing that happens in in
Austin that
I had to introduce you to which is
since I've been here when you join a new
group at a party or a gathering or
whatever and you get introduced by the
one person that you probably do know in
that Circle they usually tell the group
what you do and that allows everyone to
bypass the bragging razor because your
friend bigs up your best achievements
but again it's a reliable adjudicator
presumably I'm not going to lie about
what you know he's got a 17-inch penis
and I'm pretty sure that he's got the
world high jump record and he's like the
first man on the moon like I'm not gonna
say that right I'm going to say the
things reliably that that people can can
assume so next one I love this one
instagram razor when you see a photo of
an influencer looking attractive on
Instagram assumed that there were 99
worst variations of that photo you
haven't seen they just picked the best
one 100 and me and Josh my business
partner when we travel around will be in
sometimes very nice restaurants and we
see the beautiful couple okay like I
don't think it's them necessary but the
kind of Tommy Fury Molly main looking
couple not referring to them and he's
just kind of there staring into the
distance and she'll be there just going
through her phone of like infinite
photos of her and then on this girl
trying to find the right filter one of
the biggest red pills I had recently was
where I was at a bar and then I looked
over and there's a girl on a photo of
herself and she was face tuning it live
in real time and I now realized you it's
the classic where's the sausage made and
you've got to realize that everything on
Instagram that you see is absolute
it's just it's just not true it's the
metaverse it really is the amount of us
Everyone's an animated character
completely edited it's it's bizarre I
love the fact that
you have to assume as well that this is
the best option out of what everybody
had and especially if it's someone
that's got a pretty well curated
Instagram feed that I suppose that's one
of the advantages of as you get to a
particular level with creating content
online you don't even know what's going
on it's you know the spin the wheel
thing I have no idea what video goes out
each day like the shorts team finds
things that they love and sometimes
they'll be like oh this bit with Mark
Normand was really fun like you should
maybe put that out but they treat me
like a child like they've got a strategy
and they know what they're doing so I'm
like oh okay well I guess I'm just like
uh close your eyes and put your
hand in here celebrations tin and pull
out of today it's a bounty tomorrow it's
a malteser a good razor as well kind of
related to this is both these razors are
trying to avoid signals and then try and
actually study the noise so like not not
the noise sorry but the actual thing So
Meta games I think are super important
because you can learn a lot so I have
this rule which is
if I want to work with a personal
trainer I want the personal trainer to
be an insane shape and that's way better
than any marketing Spiel he can give for
me if I see a SAS product which is
selling landing page software I want
when I click on their landing page for
that software to be incredible like the
landing page should look if you're if
you're the landing page software guy and
your landing page isn't great that's a
sign one of my favorite one of my heroes
throughout history in marketing space is
David Ogilvy and David Ogilvy I forgot
which magazine it was they wrote a
headline which is is David Ogilvy a
genius question mark
and Ogilvy was a great marketer because
the way he marketed himself he replied
to that headline by getting his lawyer
to sue them for the question mark or at
least that's the story that he released
I go even within that you can see how
good he is at Market he doesn't have to
say like what he's done there is genius
so whenever you can study these meta
games which is not what people say what
they do or how they carry themselves is
super super important
narcissism narcissism razor if you're
worried about people's opinions remember
they are too busy worrying about other
people's opinions of them 99 of the time
you're an extra in someone else's movie
yeah and then just when you realize
everybody else has a separate video game
that they're playing
and you're just they're too busy when
you're thinking about them and you're
worried about them assume the amount of
thought you give to other people they're
giving to you and then you realize how
delusional that is one of my friends was
chatting about Envy recently and he was
talking about how he wants to get rid of
Envy as a thing I mean one thing that's
useful With Envy is to realize that
there's somebody out there who's
so envious of you who probably checks
your Instagram checks for these things
and constantly is thinking about you and
when you view it through that frame you
go Jesus that's really bad I'm actually
not that worthwhile being envious of and
you realize oh everybody else
thinks the way I think and that then
enables you to go to like third person
shooter and begin to zoom out and just
see oh
I'm not that important no there's that
quote of
um we would care far less about what
other people thought of us if we
realized how rarely they did yeah
um does this other one did you see that
story about Churchill that I posted of
the young guy who was showing around the
houses of Parliament this was good so a
young MP was being shown around
Parliament by Winston Churchill as he
wandered through the halls and offices
he asked questions about how the
building was put together Churchill
obliged and gave the young man advice on
how this world worked upon entering the
House of Commons chamber Churchill's new
friends started referring to the MPS on
the other benches as the enemy Churchill
reportedly said that's the opposition
Dear Boy the enemies behind you and what
I loved about that was it became
obviously what he's talking about is the
fact that like the people who you need
to be concerned about are the ones that
are on your team because you have
something that they want that's the
opposition you know that they're out to
get you to the people behind you the
snakes that will stab you in the back
but figuratively or symbolically I think
that
I love that story because it reminds us
that we are Our Own Worst Enemy most of
the time that we see the world as being
some sort of
um adversary that is trying to do things
against us the world gives zero
about you the world doesn't care less
literally the entire universe is
indifference to all of our existence
right nope not a blind blink and I
imagine that this is one of the reasons
why when we get to look at the night sky
it fills us with a degree of dread and
awe and insignificance that I think is
very important to keep our egos small
because we realize that everything's
just going to keep on turning but also
this goes back to the cynicism
skepticism thing you can personify the
world as being a thing you know you hear
people say stuff like this like you know
the world is an evil and mean place and
it will try and break you down I've even
nodded as Goggins said something similar
on the podcast and I there are degrees
to how it can be useful to see
um to be um alert to threats out there
and to have resilience ready for things
that are difficult to occur in the world
but the world's indifferent to
you the world doesn't care and
personifying it and creating a an enemy
out of the world I think is pointing the
finger in the wrong direction it's like
it needs to be turned inward you are the
person that knows all of your weaknesses
you can say the most disgusting terrible
things to yourself you know all of the
trigger points that you should go
through you chastise yourself for
falling short even though you've tried
your hardest like you are Your Own Worst
Enemy there will never be anybody that
can be as brutal to you as you can to
yourself
realizing that
helps you to ameliorate this adversarial
view of the world the world's just a
tool yeah it doesn't care about you that
there are some people out there who
genuinely have enemies right but it's a
rarified Strutter of people and they've
done something
yeah exactly yeah I think so there's the
nihilistic version of that or it can be
framed as noticing pessimistic which is
or nobody cares about you
what's the point then but it
goes back to the root opening of the
conversation which is
ideas are probably more important than
people like the concept of electricity
is so important or the idea of critical
thinking or whatever it is this is why
ideas are so much more important and you
can find
as a atheist or an agnostic you can find
God to some extent in these ideas
something that's way bigger than you
that can last way longer than you that
is so so damn important there was a
one that I came up with this is my my
first one I'm running it into the mix
which you'll have seen before Schultz's
razor do not attribute to group group
conspiracy that which can be explained
by cancellation anxiety so that that's a
great one there's the Cummings
razor as well which kind of forks on the
idea which is Balaji one of my favorite
followers on Twitter tweeted out
why don't why doesn't every government
in the world have a dashboard so you can
see how well they're doing it is well
think of the core map you could debate
over the core matches you can even
debate how you measure them and maybe
have different parties
and things like that but all the core
measurements number of homeless people
on the street obesity rates death rate
why why don't we have a bbc5 channel
where you can just tune in like a CEO
checking their dashboard and we don't
operate that way
um and Dominic Cummings Boris is former
right-hand man retweeted that and said
and I call this Cummings Cummings razor
which is whenever you get confused by
politicians or you think it's some great
conspiracy theory it's basically this
which is Cummings wrote I can confirm at
the time Boris does not have a dashboard
that he checks every day it's not run by
it like a CEO he just reacts to
newspaper stories that come in each day
if everybody saw this they'd sell
everything and flee and that's a
fundamental problem is yeah there's not
actually a lot of malice that's going on
it's just a complete lack of strategy
design everything gwynda had a post
today that was money the idea of
sinister Elites controlling everything
is popular because it's more comforting
than the truth that even our leaders
don't know what they're doing and
Society is ruled mostly by chance
so good there was this this other idea
called compensatory control do you
remember I I taught you about this ages
and ages ago compensatory control
um so it's Rich another Richard shotton
here so he's talking about how
um people that were very early on before
there was reason to believe that it was
a lab leak uh people were um
attributing to Global conspiracy the
fact that we had this pandemic that was
released like the people that were right
weren't right because they were educated
they were right because they were
closing their eyes and throwing it at a
dartboard if they're right at all uh
compensate we control when we feel
uncertain when Randomness intrudes Upon
Our Lives we respond by reintroducing
order in some other way superstitions
and conspiracy theories speak to this
need it is not easy to accept that
important events are shaped by random
forces this is why for some it makes
more sense to believe we are threatened
by the grand plans of malign scientists
than the chance mutation in a silly
little microbe
we just want to personify you see
whether it's that personification again
as well and one of the big reasons is
that the world is chaotic we try to
bring order to that chaos by
personifying it so many different things
that we could do what should we focus on
where should I put my time am I doing it
right am I doing it right please just
tell me if I'm doing it right
and as soon as you can create a
narrative
it's no longer random chaos oh there's a
story it's like Harry Potter or it's
like succession or it's like Pretty
Little Liars going back to what we said
earlier now you can never guess their
opinions for high agency people one of
the things I love is as soon as somebody
kind of and I can be nearly this as well
I'm sure you can but someone kind of
steamrolls with their identity belief or
whatever their team sport is it's just
if you had to give the best version of
the other team's opinion what is it then
you just see a crumble a lot of the
mongers mongers it's like steam mining
something you just completely see it
crumble and I'll often they'll go well
there is no argument for it and he said
well therefore this is why did why did
that's such a that is the most insane
perspective that totally disregards the
um
fundamental way that humans work
if you believe the same things that your
opponent believed you would be convinced
by it too yeah as soon as you can be
convinced that two plus two equals four
you can no longer unsee the fact that
two plus two equals four until somebody
convinces you of something else like you
don't get to choose to be convinced
right you just are it just happens now
you can refuse to listen to things you
can be bone-headed around stuff but once
you're convinced that's it it's game
over so understanding
that if you were that person you would
have that belief as well I don't mean in
a we have no free will determinism type
scenario that their particular Suite of
understandings and worldview perspective
has resulted in them believing this
thing which is counter to what you
believe I learned this from gwynda as
well he's coming back on a couple of
weeks uh rogerian rhetoric so it's kind
of like the
um
uh what's the dialogue method that the
Greek philosopher came up with was it
Aristotle or
people are going to be screaming into
their airpods anyway there's this like
the Socratic method for that
um
rajira and rhetoric's kind of a little
bit like the Socratic method but it's
more investigative so you're almost
trying to work out just trying to work
out what's true through asking questions
and there isn't Socratic method seems to
be more like asking questions so that
this person arrives at the outcome that
you want them to it's like you know the
Earth being flat like could you maybe
think that it could be due to this could
it maybe due to that could it maybe and
you try to guide somebody toward an
outcome regiring rhetoric seems to be
less
biased it's got less of a um an agenda
to it and uh yeah I I love that as an
outcome because you're like I just want
to find out I just want to know I want
to know what that person believes
because if I believed it I would be
convinced too leaning in with curiosity
versus like immediate judgment is and
sometimes you may change your mind and I
feel you can see that at like a
political level or a societal level but
then you zoom in all the way at the
micro and you everyone can relate to
this where
go on search facebook.com if you're old
enough and click on your own profile and
go back five years and you'll cringe for
whatever reason you will you will cringe
whether it's the outfit you wore or the
person you were dating the opinions that
you had and if you have if you aren't
cringy and then you you definitely
should be because you don't involved as
a human being however you then have to
price in out five years from now
what am I going to be thinking and
that's one of the things if you can
start skipping ahead to that question
now versus waiting the five years maybe
you'll actually get to that point in a
year the worst thing is man when you do
this game which both of us have done
Lots right
what in five years time is The Wheels on
the suitcase of my life that I should be
looking at right now where are the
blindingly obvious changes that I need
to make that I'm going to wish that I
did earlier that I'm going to wish that
I committed myself to
if you do the game of what do I wish
that me 10 years ago changed uh altered
did
adjusted in terms of texture of
existence or the way that I perceive the
world lots of those are still going to
be the same ones that you need to do now
yeah for 10 years time yeah like it's
the same pattern it's the same way skin
has the idea of Bridging the Gap where
the mistake he made five years ago
it'll be a theme of something that will
keep occurring and yeah the actual
specific mistake may change but it could
even just be the fact that I keep
thinking I figured out the answer so you
go you look back yourself five years ago
well I figured out now but you've
not priced in the five years from now
you're gonna go oh thank I've
actually figured it out now and it's the
same thing each time going back to the
sekoko thing I had this the weirdest one
again a lot of alone time can both be
great but also very bad
I don't know where this idea is I think
it's even my greatest idea or my worst
idea yeah and I've thought about turning
into a guided meditation which is
meditations useful you can kind of
observe yourself but as uh APS agnostics
people who don't have an immediate
religion to fall into they don't have
really any alternative to prayer and I
really like the kind of Jeff Bezos deaf
Bears minimization framework as well as
the kind of Roy it's just a video game
and I came up with this thing I just sat
there with no phone no nothing my mind's
just wondering
and a little bit of Christmas Carol
thrown in there where
you calm your breathing and you skip
ahead
seven years in the future
and you kind of go you take off the
VR headset and you now as you are now
listen to this podcast was just a
complete VR trip you're actually 85
years old and you're in the worst Care
Home imaginable and as your eyes slowly
open you begin to realize
then you try and embody this and feel
the emotion that you're you if all your
worst traits took over if all your
pessimism took over if all your low
agency took over if all you're isolating
yourself from your friends and bitching
about people everything that you can
think about your worst version of
yourself took over you're in a care home
where there's cockroaches on the
floor and the nurses never come in to
see you
and as you stumble around you're just
repeating all the mistakes that you've
made in your head repeating all them and
like physically feel that emotion
and then as you're feeling that
intensity
you get a knock on the door you move
over with your Zimmer frame and your
hips that feel like you've just run a
marathon the day before and standing
back as you open the door is the
absolute best version of yourself and
for whatever reason he's he's lean he's
like he's got none of the injury issues
he's just built like RFK yeah he's built
like RFK and his prime he's on all the
creatine right he looks fantastic and he
pulls up an iPad and he plays you all
the amazing memories where the
best version of you took over and you
feel that emotion to such an extreme
intensity of that envy that you have for
the best version of yourself
and you look over and there's a clock on
the wall and there's just five minutes
ticking it's how long you've got left to
live and the emotion that intensifies
but before the uh the best version of
yourself before the RFK version yourself
walks out he says okay if I could give
you the ability to go back in time now
what would you do I give you all my
money in my bank account he goes okay
let's do it let's do the trade however
you have to give me one thing today
that you're gonna show the best version
and write that down and then actually
action it and I started doing that it's
like out I almost got like
crying in a Starbucks one day yeah
you put an information Hazard warning
before posting that online which I think
is probably worthwhile it's pretty
intense thing to do are there any
realizations are there any changes that
you've made from that that aren't so
personal that you can share
um
yes I I think really just thinking in
much longer time Horizons
so thinking okay well if I go to that 80
90 year old self
I really want to play games
that I can play Forever or that I can
play for a long period of time that
video games that I can set up that
compound out as well so I've kind of
changed a lot of the way I think the way
I operate the way I work around much
more long-termism much more long-termism
because that's where all the that's
where all the gains that's what you said
to me last night of if anybody with a
bit of talent a bit of IQ a bit of
everything sticks out something for five
years like you did like playing the
video game without the scoreboard going
up but Stick it and then boom the
compounding game happens like what
percentage of your audiences come the
last 12 months like 90 more that's
insane right yeah it's so hard for
people that come from uh going back to
the education system an education system
like that to comprehend how things
compound all of a sudden but when you
can zoom out and play those long-term
games they can come back and the
beautiful thing is going back to it is
even if your podcast never took off even
if this thing never worked out and it's
still me and you just making another one
you still had fun which is kind of if
you can find a game that you can play
Forever a you'll probably end up making
a lot of money and then worst case
scenario if you don't at least it's it's
it's a fun video game anyway the early
late Razer if it's a talking point on
Reddit or Twitter you might be early if
it's a talking point a LinkedIn or
Facebook you're definitely late yeah
that's a confirmation there's a I try
and think quite a lot about future
Trends and as a result you end up going
back to what I said earlier it's VC bets
nine out of 10 will be wrong but one out
of ten will be right and the biggest
thing I have is the amount of Trends I
spotted that came via Twitter and how
far ahead you can live by living on the
right reddits the right twitters and
even now it'll be like WhatsApp chats
telegram chats things like that and you
can literally see it slowly go all the
way through and then hits Peak
mainstream when it's on Facebook or when
it's on LinkedIn dude I did this the
other day this was from this week's
newsletter and I think I told you about
this one too the parental clout gauge
I don't know this one do you know how I
know when a news story has reached
genuine mainstream significance it's not
when it Trends on Twitter or hits
daytime news or lands on front pages
it's when my dad message me messages me
on Facebook about it I see your
colleague Mr Rogan has been in the news
again he also sent me one toward the
back end of last year saying that Andrew
Tate spelled t-a-i-t that Andrew takes a
nasty piece of work isn't he and I was
like oh God Tate you've really gone full
mainstream now that's that's a good full
of fun I think as well what one thing
I've taken since a book called The
sovereign individual which is a
fantastic book predicted a lot of future
Trends and they have within that which
is this concept that if the Roman Empire
when the Roman Empire fell since like
476 A.D or whatever
um
they didn't acknowledge it at the time
it wasn't people going around the Roman
Empires fell it was only with the
historians glaze that we could
acknowledge oh that's when the Roman
Empire will fall and this idea I don't
think the American Empire is ending by
any stretch of the imagination but one
day I assume it will end and the concept
that you think you'll go on CNN one day
and they'll go oh by the way today the
American Empire ended no what will
happen is it'll be 70 to 80 years
afterwards historians will declare oh
it's when X happened that it ended and
that's the reason why you really can't
Outsource things to the news because if
you wait for the news to tell you you'll
either be late or you'll be wrong
thinking about how this reflects and
works for the personal as well I learned
this from Mark Manson identity likes
Reality by one to two years there's a
lot of psychological Fallout from a
rapid change in status and this kind of
relates to the what will you in five
years think about you today what did
they wish that you had known
only in retrospect do our lives make
sense a lot of the time so that quote
about uh the funny thing about life is
that it needs to be lived forward but it
only makes sense in reverse and identity
likes Reality by one to two years means
that you are permanently permanently
playing catch-up especially if you have
big changes in lifestyle and personal
growth you know everybody that's
listening to this podcast is is working
on personal growth they're trying to
become better people every single day
which is beautiful but it's very
unstabilizing
very very unstabilizing because you know
within the space what's that uh every
seven years every single cell in your
body has changed right it's the ship of
Theseus idea that you can replace each
individual plank on this ship and after
long enough like is it the same ship and
there's also a way that girl
break up meme Pages have used this to be
like girl don't worry after seven years
there won't be a cell in your body left
that was around when you were with him
she's actually kind of a nice way to
think about it I suppose if you're
trying to get over a bad breakup but
it's very destabilizing to have all of
this stuff happening right and
especially if identity likes Reality by
one to two years it's really really
tough Okay so
who's me what does it mean to be me
right what does it mean to be me like
who am I am I the me that I aspire to be
am I to me that I am now am I the me
like it's a very very uh destabilizing
world to be in and I think that trying
to Future proof Yourself by
thinking carefully by reflecting
carefully on on what it is that
what the universal rules are that you're
trying to follow I think is a much safer
way to go about things yeah I think I
think the more rules of thumb and raises
that you can just have the more useful
that is Brian Johnson the
which one good good point the uh here's
the point I don't know a single name
that has more
people
in the public eye attached to it than
Brian Johnson Brian Johnson singer of AC
DC Brian Johnson guy that started
optimize.me forgot about him didn't you
Brian Johnson hey guys Brian here
um Brian Johnson the liver King Brian
Johnson the longevity expert in in the
marketing space that's what we call an
SEO Warfare
I want about the longevity expert where
he has uh the 4 P.M is it 4pm Brian or
5pm Brian yeah yeah he just he's fired
him he doesn't let him make a decision
but yeah I think the more rules of
thumbs that you can have it simplifies
things and then I actually think the
ultimate hack we've been speaking about
a lot whilst I've been here is who you
are around and I know that's the kind of
oldest Dale Carnegie Trope but the
memetic forces I I wrote this essay a
while ago which is cognitive biases are
a bit of a scam or they've been sold
incorrectly so cognitive don't tell
Shane Parish cognitive biases I think
you'll agree which is cognitive biases
are pessimistic and low agency versus
you can actually just reframe them same
way you take the simulation hypothesis
and end up with video game hypotheses
you can reframe them up to the optimism
High agency stack and its cognitive
superpowers so you can just move things
like so mimesis everybody talks about
mimesis often in a negative frame model
you just copy your desires from other
people and there's some truth to that
and some beauty to that but also you can
actually use that as a tool I
mean maybe a lot of these things have
actually been designed not as cognitive
biases but things that are very
hyperbolic discounting but you've
managed to reverse that what's the name
that you've given to the study by
historians question have you named it
yet oh the the what is ignored by yeah
have you named that yeah so what is
ignored by uh the media that will be
studied by historians and then people
point out well there was this one
example where the media mentioned this
the whole thing of it is like the media
historian Gap so what is super prominent
uh so what is not prominent in the media
right now that I think will be
humongously portioned up by history and
there's so many things when you begin
it's another question it's another open
but you leave at the audience and versus
like oh this is the thing here's my
answer I've got a list of ten the
headline death Gap the headline death
Gap so this is image maybe Dean can
whack it on the screen of what headlines
say
will cause your death or what they focus
on versus what will and obviously
terrorism is like off the charts things
like that are off the charts versus
heart disease gets almost no mention in
the media and it is absolutely humongous
I have this uh bit that you did with
Peter Atia where
the is it the mortality gap between
smoking and non-smoking smoker and a
non-smokers 40 the mortality gap between
the bottom 25 of exercise fitness and
the top two percent is 400 so here's a
question for you an open loop for you
where is the where's the great Pro
exercise campaigns right now if it's if
it's 10x or however much X the the
difference and if we can save that many
lives there's because I collect like the
best ads of all time and there's one in
there which is uh like smoking and
there's an actual study on smoking ads
that the US government did it saved
millions of lives they expect so where's
the pro exercise campaigns they don't
exist based up based off that based off
purely off that data alone they should
exist on mass the interesting the reason
that the question is interesting and
I've I've called it a Max Steel question
because Peter thiel's question of what
do you believe that most people is it
most people would find abhorrent and
most people would disagree with
uh it's like yeah what what do you
believe that everybody else essentially
disagrees with you on it right yeah I
feel like again like everything I'm a
budget version of a much budget
version of Peter teal yeah so not even
as gay
who knows the knight's young right um so
on that point yeah the media historian
Gap and then you begin to see it
everywhere it was more like a point of
annoyance where I just see these things
like why is that not getting discussed
and it goes back to opportunity cost as
well where what are the things that we
aren't discussing because we're focused
on things like that the more important
things Fast and Furious turn Fast and
Furious time well I mean we've said this
actually this is an interesting one I
used to say five years ago
um most of the greatest minds of the
21st century have had their time working
out how to get people to click on ads
yeah but that changed about three years
ago to many of the greatest minds of the
21st century have had their time taken
up arguing about whether men and men and
women are women or not which is also
true like you know
John Peterson very formative for me uh
during my intellectual Awakening from
Manchild to adult infant and
I love his insights around the
existential pain of living I don't go to
him for insights around Sports
Illustrated models
does just better things and the weird
thing about some of the ideologies that
have captured attention of the opposite
side so you understand about how
um
cultural memes are also evolved too
right that the ones that are built
um to propagate and to be continued to
the ones that stick around and there are
other ones that don't right cultural
memes act the same way that genetic
genes do too
um but there's something that happens on
the opposite side of the fence that it
causes the effective cultural memes that
stick around are good at triggering us a
response from the other side they
trigger an antibody response which
further propagates the meme because it
lends more Credence to it now sometimes
I suppose the opposing side could keep
on battering away to the point where it
gets destroyed I think the word woke and
the word politically correct are two
good examples of that that comedians
used it to it was so quickly turned from
non-ironic to ironic and and mocked
through satire that no one uses the word
woke in a non-ironic way anymore
everyone that uses it is using it as a
piss take so there are ways that you can
repurpose it it's not an argument to
never push back against Bad ideology but
it is an argument to realize that if you
start to play the game of the other side
whatever side you're on and whichever
side you hate if you begin to play that
game by pushing more attention toward
what they're doing
you do uh
it's like a a Hydra it like just chop
one of their heads off and it grows too
more well if you look at kind of the
root structure the conversation today if
you actually zoom out it's constant gaps
right so you've got the media historian
Gap you've got the thinking cost Gap the
gap between what I I should be thinking
about versus that and the Beautiful
Things Are is that these are questions
are the answers that you need these are
questions that you can kind of explore
for the Transformers Fast and Furious
Gap right like what what's the the media
focusing on
there's questions that you can kind of
explore for a lifetime as well as it's
quite a decentralized thing it's the
audience can then participate that model
versus hey here's the answer I would
love to create a
page of some kind I guess it can just
happen in the comments but it would be
great for you to put a page out what is
neglected by the media but will be
studied by historians if you crowd
source that yeah that'd be that'd be a
fascinating one and then you can
obviously retrospectively see it
throughout time as well
um there's so many of those Gap that's
another one that I two that I have at
the minute which is
what problems can't cap what problems
aren't we solving because capitalism
can't solve them what like
I think I think so we spoke about this
one cyber bullying I think that's a
really difficult problem for capitalism
to solve because the incentives aligned
to get people to be online yeah that's a
real difficult one and I think therefore
you've got you've got to maybe have some
kind of Enterprise idea or something
outside the box for that I have another
one which is like the the product
marketing gap which is most people think
they hate marketing but they don't they
just hate it when marketing is better
than the product
um the the secret or optimism exact
exactly that um and I one thing I'd
leave for the audience to I'd recommend
I always recommend this my friend Julian
Shapiro sent me it which is this
documentary searching for Sugarman
you've still not senior have you anger's
meter no no end sorry watch that tonight
so searching for Sugarman
um spoiler alert is about a musician who
was more talented than Bob Dylan um
everyone who worked with him was like
this guy's incredible he's going to be
the next big thing and he just
disappeared there's rumors that he set
himself on fire like what happened to
this guy
um and meanwhile
in South Africa his music became a big
thing during the apartheid he was bigger
than Elvis he sold hundreds of thousands
of records and everyone in South Africa
was like he was he was an icon but
everyone thought he died or whatever
turns out the guy was just a builder on
a building site for the rest of his life
and it's only thanks to the internet
beginning to start that he realizes that
he was the superstar in South Africa and
I quote the Rodriguez effect which is
when you have a incredible
product people think decided oh you just
build it they will call him if you have
an incredible product but no that's
that's the importance sometimes of
marketing that if you don't actually
Market someone who's in talented as him
you end up with something like Rodriguez
where they have the most Talent I'll
give you one of the most talented
artists of his generation who never
truly took off apart from he had that
little win in South Africa but he never
took off elsewhere tell me about Kanye
West's market research oh it's my
favorite one so this is what I call the
Olsen thermometer so there's this going
back to finding Niche content on the
Internet is this Diplo animation where
Diplo is chat about he gets called up to
Cat by Kanye to work on I'd argue
probably one of his best albums which is
Watch the Throne him and Jay-Z and he
goes in the studio he's producing beats
and he looks over I know you're saying
earlier your artist's friend does like
e-cigs everywhere and there's things on
the floor in Kanye Studio there's just
the Olsen twins and Diplo is like why
why are Mary Kate and Ashley here Mary
Kate and Ashley Olsen and Kanye says oh
they're my thermometer for what white
girls like in music so I just play tunes
and see what they like and I go
obviously that's the most can you think
ever but it's also genius which is when
you have
and when you're creating something for
yourself it's really easy but when
you're creating something for different
demographics having an awesome
thermometer in the room is very very
useful the Friendship recession another
one that the ignored by the media was
studied by historians yeah yeah I think
that you know the number of men who
reported having zero close friends in
1990 was three percent in 2020 was 15
um the I mean people are starting to
talk about it with young girls there's
this recent study that came out I think
it's like 60 percent of teenage girls in
America say that they have persistent or
constant feelings of hopelessness like
it's just the most brutal I would love
to see the study and actually break down
what's going on
um Global millionaire migration what's
that yeah there's the US went from I
think 10 000 millionaires net migration
to like 1500 which is like an 85 drop
really quick
um and the UK is now at a net loss
whereas elsewhere Australia the UAE
I think Canada has gone up so that's
definitely thing that just doesn't
really get talked about like why is this
happening again another one is uh
Japan's homeless rate why does Japan
have so few homeless people relative to
the rest of the world they might be
lying with their statistics who knows
and it's so it's so low it's insanely
low a lot of the reasons that when you
actually watch documentaries about it is
these gaming cafes so that that's one
question too so they live in gaming
living live in gaming cafes the people
who would be homeless like this kind of
like a bed and a chair and they play
games which is obviously a terrible
outcome but is it better than somebody
sleeping on the streets good question to
pose another one that I think will
become bigger with the next election
cycle which you already take advantage
of this is something they're called a
great social media merge so I got this
idea from Mr Beast which is
every platform for the first time ever
is kind of you have that unbundling then
bundling effect everything's just
merging on this kind of tick tockization
of real shorts but even Reddit even
Twitter's now going on video and you're
going to see this Spotify Spotify Amazon
so all you back in the day you needed to
create something for LinkedIn then
something for this and it meant actually
going viral was so much harder whereas
now it's actually never been easier to
go viral because the same clip because
every platform's bundling together can
go on mass viral and I don't think they
priced in how quick are people are going
to get famous yeah that's looking at
content strategy there's certainly
different audiences that it resonates
with so just because something that's
916 vertical we put stuff that reliably
does well on Instagram that falls flat
on its ass on Tick Tock
um animation videos reliably do well on
Instagram
can't even get off the ground on YouTube
no one cares so there is
um although the format of the platform
maybe the same the physics the drive it
are different different but I wouldn't
be surprised if over time those begin to
merge more and more together another
thing on this specific topic is I have
one point in the essay of don't ignore
India I think in the uh it's possibly
the most fascinating country right now
which particularly is a British and
American Media doesn't really get
focused on that much so Indians are now
the number one population in the world
they're overtaking China this year or
last year they export more in software
engineering than Saudi Arabia's in oil
so there's so much going on there
they're the number one users of every
single social media platform so number
one uses a WhatsApp number one uses a
Facebook and one use of Instagram and
one uses of YouTube which means that if
you're going to be creating things
online they're going to be there like in
the area and also India bear in mind
obviously previously the British Empire
where India was a colony of Britain has
now flipped so India's economy the other
uh last year overtook the UK and again
that's barely discussed but 20 years
from now we're gonna go that was a big
event yeah uh an interesting Insight I
learned from a couple of tech YouTube
friends with massive channels when they
do
um
expensive like Apple devices their RPM
and their CPM per thousand on AdSense on
the back end of YouTube is very high but
if they do cheap Android devices tons
and tons of Indians watch it and that
drives through the floor Android's huge
there yeah
um also Ali abdall talks about Ali's
from some subcontinental Heritage and
when he does book summaries his book
summaries often listened to or watched
by people from India but it drives his
CPM through the floor so he's like he
needs to balance Revenue with but again
I think I think you're going to see I
know we spoke about this a long time ago
where remote work was the best thing
ever to happen to Skilled people in the
developing world and short people oh
yeah and yeah quite a little pin that
one and skillless people in the
developed world because all the money is
going to flow out and again that will be
something that will be spoke about five
years from now as all this money flows
out to what Balaji calls the ascending
world and the descending world as a
better model versus developed and
developing world that's the ultimate
meritocracy it's the ultimate
meritocracy but what will happen is
people will not like that because you'll
see all this money and then all of a
sudden the the cpms in India will get
higher and well also it's it's going to
drive populist uprisings more and more
you know if you we need stronger borders
okay please try and police your virtual
borders for a Workforce like you've got
this cohort of seven million Prime
working Agent Man between the ages of 22
and 50 who are not working they're not
in education employment or training
needs
um they spend a few thousand hours on
average per year playing video games 50
of that time is either on prescription
drugs or smoking weed
from this 7 million man cohort seven
million out of 330 million isn't much
but when you look at
uh capable men within that age bracket
it's actually a massive proportion
huge huge number
if those people aren't going to work
there is a vacuum that will be filled by
other workers from elsewhere another one
on this is literally this point of
what's neglected or what's ignored by
the media will be studied by historians
is the bricks so if you combine the
bricks so like Brazil Russia India China
South Africa and I think uh Korea as
well that's okay to see it's a c for
China and yeah that's true actually but
they're literally about to overtake the
G7 in terms of economic size it's like
the g7's going down like down relative
to Global GDP and that's going like that
and again these will be things that they
will not talk about the news going back
to the Roman Empire Point earlier nobody
says Roman Empire's Fallen it's the
historians that say that so the
historian frame is so much more useful
but again you can see going back to what
I said earlier there's the way I think
or it's probably sometimes you end up
visualizing weird things in bed as we
discussed earlier but there's a lot of
root structures and themes there of
these gaps of taking the historian's
perspective both at the societal level
and also at the individual level yes the
future you right looking back exactly
the same uh I think my two
my two certainly at the moment will be
that population collapse that's a big
one I brought about that one that's a
huge one absolutely massive I keep
harping on about it
um it's an interesting
it's not even necessarily ignored by the
media it's disincentivized to be spoken
about by the media because it runs
counter to a climate change narrative
that this is what we should be focused
on AI risk I think is still now largely
in the public seen as like a well you
know but I can get it to tell me the
recipe or I can get it to tell me five
interesting stories about Winston
Churchill and yeah you can but
I mean in if the people that are
concerned if like Eleazar yukowski is
right then
there is no no there's going to be no
historians in the future to be able to
worry about what happened in the past in
any case so it doesn't really matter
it's going to be all paper clips uh
YouTube is the new TV yeah this is a
crazy start and one of my new favorite
things when I see a viral YouTuber I go
in the comment section and the amount of
times I'll say hey X I'm a 15 year old
and I love your business content it's
just flooded and if you actually see you
can find the image I post on Twitter
where YouTube now is something like 25
of kids say they spend almost all their
time or such a significant proportion of
their time on YouTube and you're then
seeing this war that play out to the
attention economy where you have like
centralized major Studios so Netflix
Amazon Prime Disney all these which is
kind of top down we pay billions for
ideas but the best directors in the
world when we create that versus bottom
up which is like YouTube
anyone can go viral it's completely
decentralized and I wouldn't be
surprised if YouTube ultimately I think
they'll both win but I think YouTube
will eat more and more of the attention
Market I'm pretty sure that the amount
of time spent on Tick Tock uh last year
versus uh
Netflix Netflix watch time
let's see
uh I did not mean that
watch time
um Insider intelligence predicts that
users over the edge of a team will spend
an average of four 58 minutes per day on
Tick Tock this year compared with 48.7
minutes for YouTube Oh Netflix still
within the leader at 62 minutes so it's
like 58 minutes a day on Tick Tock 48
minutes a day on YouTube 62 minutes a
day on Netflix that's for people over
the age of 18 right so under the age of
18 is probably going to be pivoted a lot
that's like that's that's three hours of
your day here's an interesting one right
the number of hours that people have in
the day hasn't changed but the number of
the amount of time that people spend on
online platforms has
that time has to be squeezed from
somewhere yeah you don't just get to
create this time from nothing so when
people talk about you know what have
been the massive changes why is why the
discourse is this way in the mental
health and all of the rest of the stuff
look at it as a hardware problem as
opposed to a software problem is it the
globalist conspiracy is it the estrogens
in the water and the stuff it might
contribute to it a little bit maybe it's
the fact that foreign
years ago the total amount of screen
time that people spent was probably on
average like two hours or one hour a day
and now it's including work it's
probably closer to 10. so let but let's
go back to the beginning of the
conversation optimism agency right so if
you look at when the smartphone first
launched it was magic pocket computer
wow how incredible this is that I get
this thing that sits in my
pocket and I can reach anybody do
anything I can watch Richard Feynman
lectures whenever I want I could go on
Stanford University I can I can chat to
somebody in India just sat here right
now like that is incredible 10
years later brain killing device what's
what's going on we've gone all the way
from the optimism High agency all the
way down to pessimism low agency and the
number one which I never thought would
be my most popular essay in terms of
when I meet people that they want to
talk about going back to the third door
like what is the thing that no one's
discussing
is I call it the smartphone Paradox so
right now there's two things people are
presented with smartphones either one be
a phone addict who's addicted to it 12
hours a day every single day refreshing
it and yeah you get the upsides of
constant optionality and things like
that but you're stuck to your phone all
day or you've got the phoneless Luddite
who leaves his phone at home or leaves
our phone at home which is great but you
can't get an Uber anywhere if you've got
an idea you can't use your notes if your
mum's ill you don't find out until four
weeks later
um and you so you have I have the two
virgin memes like the phoneless ladai
and then the phone addict which is the
two options that have been presented by
Society right now and then I was like
okay well where's the where's the
Wheeled suitcase right now and I came up
with
the cocaine phone and the kale phone so
this is my cocaine phone here this is my
kale phone here and rather than have a
phone you're addicted to or no phone
that you're addicted to what about this
so on the kale phone essentially is all
the positive optimistic apps notes
Google Maps utilitarian Uber audible
Kindle and it's sometimes so boring I
just can't even be asked checking it and
if anybody wants to get in touch I've
got like a few emergency contacts that
have this number so I still have if
anything kicks off I've still got that
and then on my cocaine phone it's wild
Tick Tock Instagram everything on there
and what's really interesting about this
is when I spend all my time on my KL
phone so I usually won't check my
cocaine phone to like one or two p.m in
the afternoon
it completely resets my Baseline so then
when I use the cocaine one I'm I'm bored
of it right now it's too much after
about an hour and I want to go back and
that single piece alone I get people
writing to me weekly saying this thing's
like completely changed it so I call
that the smartphone Paradox and it goes
back to well you can kind of go oh well
Apple when are they going to fix this or
tick tock's evil it's like or you can
you can take it into your own hands and
design some wheels in the suitcase the
bottom line is that you need to take
control of your own technology I would
go as far as to say that like my
relationship with technology has
probably been the most consistent
challenge that I've had to fight with
over the last decade right it's
something every single year when I look
at my annual review that no matter how
disciplined I've been I always want to
be more disciplined and I always see it
as a a challenge I was thinking
I could have would have should have done
better with that
um but I'm cocaine kale and then a third
one as well right like I've got three
and the phone yeah cat Academy phone
um I've been rolling with that for a
long time and that's been a big do not
have social media on the main phone it's
the most and the beauty of that is you
get the upsides of you get the upsides
of having the phone all the craziness of
social media finding like random stories
what we chatting about earlier but all
the upsides of having peace of mind and
being able to detach and mindfulness I
think Audible and podcasts yeah podcast
notes I everything you can think of
being able to get an Uber somewhere like
all the basics and again Society
presents these two extremes that you
render the Spectrum but there's always a
third door that exists the scale of
farmer marketing yeah that's a big one
um again going back to as someone who
loves advertising loves
collecting the best ads of all time only
us and New Zealand are allowed to run
pharmaceutical advertising I can't quote
the exact ones I think it's MSNBC
two of a bigger big news networks in the
US their biggest advertisers are
pharmaceutical companies but it goes
back to my point earlier which is okay
that's true that's the thing that exists
should that exist that's open for debate
that's an open question but where are
the ICONic exercise campaigns if we know
that it can have a 500 increase
taking somebody from the bottom 25 of
exercise to the top two percent where
where are those campaigns and why aren't
the government investing in them I put
out a thing of if any government wants
to invest DM me and I'll help well
speaking of DMS yet so speaking about
government investment you've got the
Great Tech neglect yeah so this is one
of my favorite ones which is I could
talk about ignored by the media studied
by historians the UK government posted a
job role for the head of cyber security
for the UK government
and the proposed salary was 55 000
pounds which again for a lot of people
is a lot of money don't get me wrong but
for the head of cyber security
how is that how
is that possible but when you think
about your job is in cyber security and
the number one
floor that all cyber systems have is the
human element every single hacker
fundamentally is a human hacker first
not a computer hacker almost everybody I
think it's called Soft hacking or
something like that where they try and
look for the human element in if this
guy is a girl is getting 57
000 pounds per year
like how many Bitcoin do you think that
a rogue nation has to be able to bribe
that person there's your vector of
attack yep and the two things I've been
really focused on the last kind of 12 20
more 24 months is traveling and studying
different cultures because you go why
does Japan have so a few homeless people
or how can you get UK is doing this but
meanwhile in Singapore they pay the
average politicians something like 750
000 and they have kpis based off how
well the country's performing so study
different cultures travel a lot and you
begin to see those gaps as well as when
you study history you begin to go you
begin to take a historian's frame to the
present moment
how incredible modern Aviation is this
is the wildest one and I every time I
get on an airplane even when I flew here
I always say to myself I go and this is
even a gratitude hack I go I'm gonna die
today let's be taking off especially
because I rant about how modern Aviation
is I gotta be the most ironic death for
the Pro Mod Aviation guys Elon Musk says
that of the most entertaining outcome
will happen of the guy that rants about
how amazing Aviation is will die on a
flight so
his two stats I think it's 2021 the
number of deaths on uh airline in 2021
was around about 120 to 180 depending on
the statistics you look at the number of
cardiffs was around about 1.1 million so
and think about how much more dangerous
an airplane taking off is and that is
completely neglected I think probably
because it's a positive story and we
don't want to focus on it or we just
take it for granted the same way we take
the sewage system for granted the same
way we take electricity system for
granted all these great ideas we take
for granted and then we focus on all the
nonsense with the opportunity costs that
we have
is humongous that we don't think about
how wonderful modern Aviation is well we
have this threat detection system right
and we also have a smoke detector
principle which is it is far better for
us to assume that something bad is going
to go wrong and it not happen than us
assume that something is going to go
well and that not occur like there is a
bus Bush that shakes over the far side I
can either be scared because it might be
aligned and run away and it might be a
line or it might not but the cost of me
running away is relatively low the
customer being eaten is very high so we
always have this negativity bias it's
inbuilt into us it is your job to swim
upstream against that and stats like
that I think are very very important to
remind you like the I mean what's the
chance of you dying in the car on route
to the airport
they say the most dangerous thing about
a fly is the drive to the airport
well I mean the I remember it's in
Matthew Walker's book where he talks
about how the number of doctors that
have done us I think it's surgeons the
number of doctors are surgeons that have
worked 12-hour shifts in a hospital that
upon their drive home crash and then get
taken back to their own hospital to be
worked on because of how sleep deprived
they are wow I think I there's a book
called Black Box thinking which I
recommend which studies the aviation
industry where they compare well why are
Airline deaths going down so much
meanwhile hospital deaths are going up
so much and he has a few interesting
hypotheses about cultural things and
with a black box they literally observe
once a plane crash is what happens it
records it and because often the people
are dead there's no ego involved so they
can objectively assess it but the
lessons from the aviation industry
should be applied everywhere and this
ties into the next point which is what
happened to ticker tape parades like
ticker tape parades Peter till has this
great point where they used to be huge
people would go out in the street and
applaud JFK applaud these great
individuals and it started off in the
1910s became super popular all the way
up to the 1970s and then just slowly
fade away the last iconic individual
really was Nelson Mandela in 1990 in New
York after that is a few sports teams
not individuals collectives a few nurses
and a few things like that but what
happened to that my thesis is like
where's the ticker tape parade for the
Wright brothers or where's the day off
for the Wright brothers because I'm
talking out that you think about how
talk about high agency individuals
well no one can agree on any cultural
Heroes anymore there is nobody they're
from the Wright brothers are up for
debate but new ones like you're not
going to throw a ticket parade for the
Wright Brothers now oh yeah you know try
and think of who do you think is the
most unobjectionable
person maybe the Rock
he probably doesn't do badly and even
then he probably scores like 51 to 49 in
the policy I mean he he did put his foot
in it to do with I think he maybe it was
a race thing and maybe it was a trans
thing a few years ago so yeah the
when the Overton window has become so
highly constrained and when concept
creepers occurred to the point where
everybody will find something that they
can justifiably be insulted by there are
landmines everywhere for somebody to
step on yeah and yeah there's a question
I have for you that I was thinking about
on the way down
we're talking about history a lot here
and studying history has given me such a
fantastic frame about these things
why is it so music is a specific thing
where people
consume a lot of music from the past
even to this day like on the way down I
love Christopher Cross Ride Like the win
one of my favorite songs from multiple
decades ago you think of AC DC Michael
Jackson all these amazing artists that's
still relevant today and people still
consume the music today versus with
social media people David prowell has
that concept of the never ending now
people only consume content the last 24
hours when you probably most people
listening to that listening to this
still apply this
but imagine if you applied that to music
where all you could listen to is the
island boys
like the music that's been made to
literary today it'd be terrible but why
do we do that for information
consumption I've not quite figured that
out yet yeah that's an interesting
question I think what we go to for music
and what we go to for the other types of
content that we consume are very
different things we go to music for a
vibe to put ourselves into a particular
kind of emotional state a lot of the
time
music seems to be a lot more Lindy
because there are universal laws no
one's going about I always say this
about Shapiro's Channel you know Ben's
got this rapidly growing Channel and
he's been very very successful on
YouTube and in podcasting and all the
rest of it no one's going back and
listening to Ben Shapiro's mid-2020
podcast episodes because they're
inherently about relevant yes they're
about the last 24 hours but there's so
much in history that is relevant or so
much amazing content out there that is
relevant so on prayer he has this other
concept of the Paradox of abundance
where right now you've never seen more
people in the Obesity levels are off the
charts another thing they're probably
ignored by the media study by historians
off the charts
but also the number of Greek people look
like Greek gods he's also off the charts
you have this weird evil barbell like
evil extremes and I think the exact's
true of information consumption I posted
this thing the other day of like the
Paradox of abundance of YouTube you can
go back to the smartphone Paradox as
well you can use YouTube to search
Richard Feynman lecturer Charlie Munger
the history of World War II how did
Winston Churchill prepare his speeches
or you can search WorldStar hip-hop
fights or the island boys and that
Paradox of abundance exists there's this
really cool quote another guinda one
here that says the combination of the
digital age constantly exposing us to
new outrages and cultural Elites
constantly creating new outrages out of
nothing has skyrocketed the number of
outrages we now face in a world
prickling with provocations we cannot
let our sensitivities roam free if we
allow ourselves to be goaded by every
invisible and visible indignation we'll
endlessly be distracted from our goals
and easily controlled by emotional
manipulators like trolls disinformation
agents and demagogues I block the easily
outraged because they're the foot
soldiers of the mob who in the old days
would have lynched people over the
neighborhood rumors those without
self-control are seen controlled by
others those without self-control are
soon controlled by others they're the
useful idiots of ideologues the tools of
tyranny
so with that I think you just show that
everybody has a thing that they can find
which is reprehensible that the person
that they're talking that they're
looking at has done which is why the
tick type parade thing has stopped who
can everybody agree on as being a hero
and if you don't have any cultural icons
that you can hold up it's very difficult
to Rally around like if you tried to
hold a ticket parade for pretty much
anybody
there would be an equally sized
anti-parade for the same thing yeah
which is insane and also I guess
goes back to the the pessimism bias uh
most people die at 25 and aren't buried
until they're 75. why this reference is
what we're trying about earlier where at
0 to 25 before that is a beautiful
design video game it's like grade one
grade two grade three grade four grade
five or year one year two year three
year four year five if you're English
and you kind of progress up like a
beautiful Milestone every single year
through High School through college
and you all of a sudden at 25 those
Milestones just become
marriage which is obviously might be on
the decline mortgage
funerals of loved ones kids kids and
then your own funeral so the amount of
Mile you go from like a milestone
so regularly to almost non-existent and
big thing I have of reasons why I think
it happens is one lack of Milestones
institutionalization
institutionalization because people go
from the education system
where they kind of sat there all day
over 18 for 18 years asking to go to the
toilet and then they're just going
I'm thrown out in the wild like a
prisoner and as a result people really
struggled to adapt to that
um I also think people just don't really
care about adults I think it's quite sad
um support group they haven't got any
support groups so the time spent with
family time spent with friends even
co-workers ultimately goes down towards
the end
um so you factor in all those things
plus that parenting switch thing uh yeah
so there's the parenting switch as well
which is you go from being The Keg you
go from having your caregivers there
your entire life support and you
supporting you supporting you and again
going back to Milestones all of a sudden
then one day you get a phone call and
you're their caregiver or they're not
even here so it just immediately
switches on you and all those things
begin to stack up which is super
depressive super like pessimistic maybe
we end on that note like super
nihilistic end but no actually the the
optimistic answer I wrote about which is
a few solutions for that which is one
create regular Milestones so I'll try
and split the year into quarters now
which is enough time to Sprint at things
but also then have a week off completely
reflect and then rebuild the plan so
then you have like four Milestones per
year two
um try and schedule things in with
friends regularly family regularly whole
like you can use you use your Google
calendar for like weekly meetings with
people at work you can use it for
friends you can use it for family as
well three I think we also have a lack
of religion in current society and we've
kind of thrown the baby up with a baffle
a lot of atheists look down on it but
those regular rituals
um a thing bigger than you that you're
working on so important to have so try
and take Sabbath's uh fasting things
like that you can take quite a lot from
religion
and all of a sudden you can then begin
to not die at 25 which I think is a huge
huge problem it's a silent problem as
well
George Mack ladies and gentlemen dudes I
love you I'm really really glad that you
came to see me in Austin what should
people do if they want to check out more
of your writing you're one of the
quickest growing guys on Twitter at the
moment where should they go yeah a few
things so
I put together all the best ideas and
resources I found at George mac.com so
you can just get that there completely
for free and I kind of update it with
time and then I'll send a Weekly
Newsletter related to that
um you can also just literally go to
George Dash mark at Twitter and then
there's also a load of great ads which
is kind of under right now the current
URLs marketingplug.com but that will
change but you'll still be relevant when
people when people hear this before we
go though one thing I'd like to say just
to break the fourth wall for the
audience me and you was sat on a beach
few years ago now and you remember what
you said to me you said
if I can get to 100 000 subscribers
and hopefully now we'll be at the
million Mark and the big thing I've
learned as a Brit touring America is
there's a lot we can take from Americans
and vice versa they are super
complimentary to their friends which we
are often quite like mocking of each
other quite insulted to each other but
proud of you man you've absolutely
smashed it and I think for a lot of
listeners out there you set an example
of an infinite game that you keep that
you keep sticking at and boom X percent
of the audience has come the last 12
months what a compounding game man and
thank you for having me my pleasure man
we're going to keep on doing it together
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe